i wanted a movie that showed in a very
funny but realistic way two
adult gay men who both prided themselves
on not needing a relationship what
happened to those men when they fell in
love for the first time what are you
into one of these boring ripped idiots
with no opinions no i'd like someone
who's physically very frail and won't
stop talking the first decision made
about casting was that my love interest
would be played by another openly gay
actor fun day
and then once we made that decision i
turned to nick and said everyone in the
cash should be openly lgbtq we both
wanted the same thing we wanted to be
really funny but let it be honest this
is a historical film first of its kind
so many people deserve to be seen who
hadn't been seen there'll be tons of new
faces that people fall in love with
[Music]
nicholas and billy
have been so genius in crafting such a
dynamic cast and a diverse cast we don't
see that often everyone's really funny
everyone has a different comedy energy
there are also gay terrorists and there
are bi-terrorists okay there are trans
terrorists too caitlyn jenner
the sheer amount of talent that has not
been utilized is mind-blowing these
people are queer and talented go figure
now i have to go to a pride party and
you're both too old to be in the pool
please leave for all of us to get to
meet and celebrate something like this
is truly an honor studio nick judd
everyone said from the beginning it has
to be authentic
oh my god do you guys remember straight
people yeah they had a nice run
you